♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW SOME SHOCKING
HONESTY FROM FAR LEFT SQUAD
CONGRESSWOMAN CORI BUSH WHO IS
SAYING SHE CAN HAVE ALL THE
PRIVATE SECURITY SHE WANTS, BUT
THAT WE NEED TO DEFUND THE
POLICE FOR A WEEK, THE LITTLE
PEOPLE, I GUESS, ALL OF US, NOT
HER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU WANT TO SEE ME DIE?
BECAUSE THAT COULD BE THE
ALTERNATIVE.
AFTER I SPENT $70,000 ON PRIVATE
SECURITY OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS AND I'M HERE STANDING NOW
AND ABLE TO SPEAK, ABLE TO SAVE
11 MILLION PEOPLE FROM BEING
EVICTED, OR I COULD POSSIBLY
HAVE A DEATH ATTEMPT ON MY LIFE.
IF I END UP SPENDING $200,000,
IF I SPENT TEN MORE DOLLARS ON
IT, YOU KNOW WHAT, I GET TO BE
HERE TO DO THE WORK.
SO SUCK IT UP, AND DEFUNDING THE
POLICE HAS TO HAPPEN.
WE NEED TO DEFEND THE POLICE AND
PUT THAT MONEY INTO SOCIAL
SAFETY NETS BECAUSE WE ARE
TRYING TO SAVE LIVES.
>> Sean: WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
THE THREATS I GET?
I AM SURE THEY MIGHT SHOCK YOU.
ANYWAY, I GUESS SAFETY, SECURITY
IS ONLY THE ARISTOCRATS AND THE
SWAMP AND THE SEWER AND NOT FOR
THE REST OF US.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION,
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW, LEO
2.0 TERRELL REL.
CONGRESSMAN, PROBABLY ALL OF US
RIGHT NOW, I WOULD ASSUME, LEO,
PROBABLY HAPPENED TO YOU, DAN,
PROBABLY HAPPENED TO YOU.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS 33 YEARS.
THIS HAPPENED MORE THAN A FEW
OCCASIONS WITH ME.
YOU GET THREATS IF YOU'RE A
PUBLIC FIGURE AND YOU EXPRESS
POLITICAL OPINIONS.
DAN?
>> YEAH, THAT IS RIGHT ANGELO,
I'M HAPPY SHE HAS PRIVATE
SECURITY BUT I'M JUST WONDERING
IF --
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, SO AM I.
>> -- IF THEY CAN AFFORD
$70,000 A YEAR.
BUT I WONDER IF THE CITIZEN SHE
ACTUALLY REPRESENTS CAN AFFORD
$70,000 A YEAR IN PRIVATE
SECURITY, AND GOD KNOWS THEY
NEED IT.
LEWIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS CITIES IN AMERICA.
YOU HAVE A ONE IN 51 CHANCE OF
BEING A VICTIM OF A CRIME THERE.
151 MURDERERS AND A HUNDRED OF
THOSE VICTIMS HAVE BEEN BLACK
PEOPLE AND THEY ARE NOT BEING
KILLED BY COPS, THEY ARE BEING
KILLED BY CRIMINALS AND
MURDERERS AND YOU KNOW WHO
CHASES CRIMINALS AND MURDERERS?
THAT IS COPS AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHO THEY WANT TO DEFUND.
81% OF THE BLACK COMMUNITY
FAVORS THE SAME OR MORE
POLICING.
HERE'S THE BIG TAKE AWAY HERE.
WE HAVE TO DO AWAY WITH THIS
NOTION THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
NOT THIS RADICAL PARTY.
THEY ARE A RADICAL PARTY.
THIS IS NOT SOME FRENCH
ACTIVIST, THAT THE DEMOCRAT
MEMBER OF CONGRESS HAD A VERY
POPULAR ONE OF THAT.
THE MEMBER OF THE SQUAD, THEY
HAVE THE HIGHEST SOCIAL MEDIA
FOLLOWING.
A REAL INFLUENCE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE IS NOT A
RADICAL TALKING POINT, IT
HAPPENED ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
IN AMERICAN CITIES, MURDERERS
HAVE GONE UP 33% THIS YEAR.
IT IS BECAUSE OF DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, SOCIAL JUSTICE BILL
REFORM, LETTING CRIMINALS OUT ON
BAIL INSTEAD OF PUTTING THEM IN
JAIL AND OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING KILLED AND HURT AND SHE
DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE.
SHE DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE.
SHE RELIES ON THESE HORRIBLE
SOCIAL JUSTICE TALKING POINTS
AND SHE'S DOING EXACTLY WHAT HER
CITIZENS AND THE PEOPLE SHE
REPRESENTS DON'T WANT.
>> Sean: THEO, I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR, I WANT CONGRESSWOMAN
BUSH COME EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL, I DON'T CARE WHAT
YOUR POLITICS ARE, WE NEED TO PR
ELECTED OFFICIALS BUT WE ALSO
NEED NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE SAFE
AND SECURE AND HAVE LAW AND
ORDER BECAUSE WITHOUT THOSE
THINGS, YOU CANNOT PURSUE
HAPPINESS, CAN YOU?
AND THE HYPOCRISY IS, FINE, SHE
WILL GET PRIVATE SECURITY, WE
WILL PAY FOR IT BUT SHE IS
SIMULTANEOUSLY DEFUNDING THE
POLICE THAT PROTECTS THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> LET ME FIRST OF ALL SAY I
AGREE.
I DON'T WANT ANY HARM TO INCUR
TO CONGRESSWOMAN BUSH BUT HOW
DARE SHE?
SHE TALKS ABOUT SPENDING 70,
$80,000 ON HER PRIVATE SECURITY
AND WHAT ABOUT THE BLACK PEOPLE
CHICAGO, L.A., WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THEY DON'T HAVE $1,100,000,
THEY ARE JUST TRYING TO PUT FOOD
ON THE TABLE.
SHE'S GASLIGHTING BLACK PEOPLE.
SHE NEEDS TO PICK A SIDE.
EITHER SHE HELPS THE BLACK
PEOPLE IN HER COMMUNITY OR SHE
GOES WITH THE CRIMINAL.
IT IS INSULTING FOR HER TO SIT
THERE AND SAY SHE'S DOING THE
WORK.
SHE IS DOING THE WORK FOR NO
ONE!
SHE IS DESTROYING BLACK
COMMUNITIES BY TAKING OVER THEIR
ONLY LINE OF DEFENSE, POLICE!
BLACK PEOPLE WANT POLICE.
FOR HER TO GO UP THERE AND TALK
ABOUT HER ABILITY TO SPEND 70,
80, $100,000, WHO IN HER
COMMUNITY HAS $100,000 TO SPEND?
IT'S INSULTING!
SHE DOESN'T REPRESE